welcome back to austin record where we
talk about whatever we
want and we have chevy cola
and the last take on one of our patreon
videos uh
steve said something about something
what is this and you are shook gentlemen
what is this it's a diamonds for hands
only fingers only
that's the roc this is the hand it's the
illuminati
the hand gesture for a vagina oh it's
the illuminati
this is the punani
you gotta show the money if you want the
punani so we we got in a hot and heavy
we had to do an off the record
immediately
immediately i was at home we were in the
group chat talking about the puss
and i was like i'm on the way let's
[ __ ] shoot this thing so it's a
debate
steve i'm shook so you do not practice
cunnilingus i don't
it's a personal choice my question is
and you are with uh a significant my
wife is nikki yes
wife nikki who i haven't met yet and
you're stunning we should meet soon
yeah um for now maybe more reasons
does she practice fellatio yeah yeah of
course of course
yeah of course i'm so sorry that's a
deal breakfast 20 21. of course she does
yeah is she better so i dumped chicks
who didn't do it
what if nicki said it was a deal breaker
that you didn't eat [ __ ]
well she didn't and then she married me
so we're good so that just shows how
you write his reign honey buns we need
to have some cocktails and talk about it
she's not that into that though she
likes to she likes to make me come she
doesn't like to come at all yep
i cannot tell if this is a hidden camera
show no she's into that i
cannot tell if this is a hidden camera
not a hidden camera at all no it's one
of those
you haven't you've heard of that though
i'm sure yeah you've heard of that
where people don't do they just they
feel like they want to serve as other
people and that's really very nurturing
very very nurturing yeah i think because
i come from a space of also being
you know i'm bisexual everyone knows
that i talk about it every time i'm here
with two women i just can't that's not
all we do you don't scissors it's not
all we do
we rock paper and scissor baby let's go
what's the paper part rock that's when
you just lay on top of each other
two sheets of paper sometimes one's like
one's already on the bed
and then i climb on a ladder and i jump
and i fall like a sheet of paper
i look heavy but i'm very light got it
and then we in the way you land
perfectly and if you don't land
perfectly
you do it again or if she's on a table
you're going through the table
it's like wwe it's like you
move remember that move that chyna used
to do where she would like slam someone
in her [ __ ] oh yeah that's
what it's like steve wouldn't know steve
would have not i wouldn't
i wouldn't go for that movie yeah you
would never i'm rolling out of that
every time i would never
so then um rock so that was paper rock
in the bedroom
it's not fisting no no
i knew that that's that's ventriloquist
when you just
you know i'm actually so good at talking
without moving my mouth
casey casey where's tiff
you're moving today is saturday today is
saturday and
that's pretty good what she's saying
though she's not accurate with her
information
not an effective communication my mouth
isn't moving
and clearly your mouth isn't moving
either dunno would have got the info
right and not moved his mouth
oh first of all you know jeff and i are
fighting right now so i the fact that
you would even bring up his name
just saying so cuddly so i i just i
don't know i can talk about this all day
so i'm so i'm so confused
you know you're a woman you know that
down there there's a lot of things that
can happen it's like a it's like a biome
right so is the penis it's out
it's an audi though it's an audi it's
not a amy yeah
there's not but there's still things
coming out of it like pee
sure why don't you tell her how so when
they 69
she's sucking on him and he's wearing a
mask and then he's pinching his nose
yeah he's just actually just laying
there yeah because he has a spiderman
mask
are you pinching your nose then what's
the point of 69. i'll do it if she's
washed it twice
i don't even want to ask this question
have you eaten ass i only eat that
that's the only thing on the menu so the
ass ass is all
a cart but he sees the vagina he's like
wait i'm sorry you truly you eat us
of course yeah like a buffet oh honey
i put a [ __ ] bib on first it is the
[ __ ]
uh cosmopolitan i cannot think of one
vegas buffet right now
you can make her ass come right but not
can't make the vagina come but
the butt color i know how to make her
butt come on
what comes out of the butt uh it's a
weird fluid yeah what doesn't come out
of the book yeah there is some weird
fluid that comes out of the butt yeah
i love now i'm just getting really
really horny to be honest and this is
not often i mean this is off the record
this is public i forgot this is this i
forgot this is public
very very very horny in public though
that's okay i'm always honey in public
can you actually you know how you can
get arrested for public intoxication can
you get arrested for public
hornification
i think if you're bonering too hard you
probably can't yeah if you have a boner
you're just walking around
a playground or something that's weird
oh no not at the park
right well yeah we're not at the park
why would we go there
or at the supermarket at those remarks
you're just knocking [ __ ]
over you're just like you're just like
knocking things off right now
you can't go near the topo chico aisle
because all the glass
balls oh it's a nightmare all the milk
cartons forget about it so you eat the
ass not the puss
yeah is that to do with your religion i
forgot i didn't explain it before but oh
religion
oh yeah oh yeah i'm a southern baptist
oh so that's in the bylines it's just
well no it's not it's not it has it's
just about
yeah it's about the females usually
serve out to the male yeah
and we really believe in that you're
already pretty progressive though by
letting her give you head
yeah yeah because that's like crossing
the line and even like eating her butt
like that's that's pretty progressive
and that's why i mean he's in l.a
progress yeah he's in l.a she's pushing
the boundaries
y'all have talked to me a lot and you
know i'm on the opposite side of that
spectrum like
women serving men excuse me it's my
religion
he used to only lick the titties but now
he licks the titties and the butt yeah
that's pretty progressive and that was
hanging out with us he's kind of pushing
himself
he's doing well i love licking teddy
true or false true absolutely if you say
false and get the [ __ ] out of it
your silence is definitely right he's
always just going down
all the time that's what is your
favorite activity to do uh besides uh
physical intercourse i mean making out
with the nose really
sucking out all the boogers you're doing
the kobe test to the ladies
the brain stump yeah yeah the brains
that the and then i do the q-tip time
in the ear in the ear
honey do you use that little tiny ear
wax moon no my tongue
right oh for my own self yeah yeah but
yeah yeah y'all have a little cotton
ball at the end oh that's nice i don't
use the cotton ball because first of all
that thing's hard to wash and it's
useless you have the chinese kit
oh i have a tiny little spoon tiny
little spoon grandpa had that
for a little oh is your earwax waxy or
flaky yellow flaky
me too it's just waxy that's why that's
the difference
so no the statistics say if you have the
waxy ear wax you don't need [ __ ]
oh if you have the yellow flaky that's
on uh ancestry.com
dot com and wikipedia yeah both it's a
cross reference studies
yeah numerous studies fauci actually
fauci chimed in
that's why no one like listened to him
during the code stuff because he was
such a proponent for that stuff yeah
early in his career well he's an
advocate for you know just
[ __ ] rights big [ __ ] rights guy
huge [ __ ] hound that guy my dad doesn't
need [ __ ] either and you should see a
picture of my mom
she's like
i don't know what that means does that
mean buff
no she's very happy very happy okay
so has this been a conversation between
you and your father oh yeah of course he
put it in my head from the beginning
never ever ever give them that real men
don't [ __ ] put their mouth there
[ __ ] is so hot
i think it's like i don't think you're
understanding where he's coming from
though
yeah because like i think you're so
stuck in your ways and so stubborn
everyone we all should be a little more
inclusive that's all i'm saying like
i think from where he's coming from if
you give it to her too fast she could
just leave whenever she wants
oh my whole thing is here's the thing i
would be okay with it if she also
doesn't go down on you
but the fact that she goes down on you
and you refuse to go down on her
she has to i dumped a chick who didn't
do it yeah i've done that too
i cannot believe the words that i'm
hearing i can't believe the words that
i'm hearing
you know i cannot believe it you know i
think you should just try just being a
little more open-minded
and just not being so like you know you
should be more inclusive have you talked
to an open-minded mormon one
moment i mean mormon words
me open-minded you gotta be more
open-legged
yeah oh not my best it's interesting
it's interesting not my best i was
trying to picture it not my best
i'm not doing you the favorite workshop
new choice um
i i guess yeah she's literally at a loss
for words yeah they used their own
are you upset for steve or upset for
nicki minaj
or just women in general women in
general definitely the entire community
the entire culture
why do women care because i thought that
like eating [ __ ] makes a guy gay
oh take off the hat take out that you
have to earn that [ __ ] hat
you have to earn that [ __ ] hat
i earned this hat that's for damn sure
how does eating buzzing make you gay
that's what i kept hearing but i thought
i just makes
men weak 13 year old boy
wait do you eat [ __ ] joe joe
do you go down nope it's pretty gross
is it because you don't i don't even
make out with the lips what makes you
think i'm gonna make out with the [ __ ]
lips
you may go with the lips no y'all are
just lying to me now
he doesn't like kissing him that much
he's not a big kisser oh to me a
romantic
night is a slow kiss to my dick
was that a haiku was that a haiku yeah
that was seven cylinders
i liked it it's a slow kiss to my dick
slow kissed yeah yeah this video is
brought to you by
warby parker warby parker is committed
to providing
exceptional vision care online and in
person
and what's really cool is i just moved
to vegas and did you know that there's a
warby parker store there
so yeah what they offer are eyeglasses
sunglasses
contacts and eye exams so if you are
next to a store you can go in the store
but what we're talking about today
is their at home try on five glasses for
free program it's pretty cool because
the glasses start at 95
including personal prescription lenses
sunglasses
progressives and blue light lenses are
also available
but here's the thing i don't really like
ordering glasses online because i
need to try them out first i have an
interesting
face shape i always buy them and i
didn't even want this and i wasted money
right
but this trihome kit is pretty awesome
because
it's free you know you get to try it on
for free and that's pretty application
to buy
so you get five to try with you and
maybe your friends and you could be like
yo do you like this that's pretty cool
how about different outfits how about
this one
that one looks cool too i actually this
one was this one and this one is my
favorites
oh different colors yeah but then this
is my favorite
favorite you know because i'm kind of
like
surfer dude but i'm also a blues
musician so yeah i really like to try
at home kit because it saves time you
don't got to go to the store especially
if you
live in a place where it's still super
on lockdown and it just saves time even
if you're not on lockdown in general
and you know a lot of times like you
don't want to buy one at a time and then
you got to go return it
oh that one didn't look good they send
you five glasses for five days you tried
it at home for free
there's no obligation you take a quiz
first though
oh they do you yeah you take a quiz and
then you if you're confused of like what
you want to do
they have a stylist on board oh that's
tight it's so cool
that's really sick yep yeah so this is
interesting to you
and you want to check out five free
glasses for five days with
zero obligation it's for free go to
warbyparker.com
off the record there's no obligation and
they even send you a free return package
for you to return so there's
zero literally nothing out of your
pocket go to warbyparker.com
off the record to try this for free get
some sunglasses to style you up
they even have this handbook to take you
step by step
it's pretty cool okay what about see
that's why
casey casey's doing it right i already
[ __ ] know the vibes i don't [ __ ]
know the vibes
are you getting energy are you getting
energy i wish don't fail us dude
i wish there was another person with a
vagina here
why for solidarity
what about you i don't really like
talking about that okay
i eat the [ __ ] how about that and then
you me it means you could be friends
yeah i have common ground we make common
ground we're right we're fine no we can
still be friends we can we can
still we know there's nothing i eat the
[ __ ] right all the time
but geo never sucks my dick promise yeah
it's weird
you know it's kind of like it's kind of
like a reverse situation okay how do you
feel about that
are you angry how do you feel about that
well i think in buddhism the
man's supposed to service the woman only
so it's like where i
how i grew up it's pretty normal where
like i always see
my dad going down on my mom
i am absolutely with boys right now and
that is just so clear
it's so clear oh my god
but they would never have sex it's just
always going down only it's only
[ __ ] stuff always playing the harmonica
all the
it time it even funnier because i used
to live with this dad
and when i went downstairs to do the
laundry his
girlfriend was sitting on the [ __ ]
lazy boy chair like this
and she had her clothes on and he was
motorboating or [ __ ] like
true i'm [ __ ] true
no i didn't i didn't lose my dad but he
was living with my dad at the time
what did you do okay what is the truth
is everyone being truthful no that's
true
that is absolutely true don't live with
your dad yes while you
did not live with your dad yeah and he
walked in on your dad 100 i don't think
you could make that up
practicing condolences on a lazy boy
hashtag ad
hashtag and then i i walked down and i
felt like i caught my teenager kids
doing naughty [ __ ] and they were hella
embarrassed because i
i was already there in the living room i
had to do my laundry and i went to go
put my laundry away and i came back out
and they're on the couch like this
just covering up with pillows and stuff
oh that's a hundred percent did your dad
talk to you about it like hey joe caught
me on the lazy boy with
babe he's talking about anything his age
you're dead right right right
what would he say yeah what are you
saying
hey son i was eating [ __ ] again he
taught you well
he taught you up as much as some rugs my
guy
but that is that is interesting i guess
i guess yeah i do know a lot of women
who don't
uh like to suck dick yeah i guess that's
only fair
i guess yeah you know i guess i'll i'm
going to accept me into your heart
accept me
i guess i'm more understanding about it
but i might try it
i think that's what it is it's like the
the not openness at all to it the
like no bottom line deal breaker of it
all that's the
you know because you know me i'm so what
would you give some tips for them to
like
try it oh sure open up their brains to
like try
put mentos on it or some [ __ ] yeah it's
a pepsi yeah what if you put like
yeah put some coffee cola on it
i mean i could yeah i could trigger what
if vagina had the power of
caffeine that would be interesting to be
interesting i've sucked my own dick
before when i was like in
like 13 years old wait well because you
have less height so then you can reach
right because
i recently got a video i don't know if
i've talked about bumble boy
bumbleboy sent me a video of him sucking
his own dick who's bumble boy
and let's talk about this a guy that i
was talking on bumble for like
oh bombo yeah yeah yeah oh his name is
bumbleboy
in my phone and we started off raunchy
i've talked about this on
uh tiger belly but repeating stories um
i want to hear this
so we started off raunchy i my roommates
convinced me to get
bumble and that night we were kind of
drinking i was about like you know
nine white claws deep nice who's
counting
and i'm feeling good and you know
[ __ ] out here single
so we match and he we immediately got
phone numbers and like it just started
off raungie i was drunk and i was down
for the ranch i'm an actress we're doing
characters you know
uh i'm a vixen tonight you know what i
mean so um
we're just like raunchy raunchy raunchy
so i kind of set the tone for ranch
you know what i mean yeah what did you
say what did you say i was just going
with it babe
you can imagine all the things anything
under the sun
it was sad are you pretty good at
sexting i'm pretty
i participate do you sext or do you do
the video vixen i did some voice notes
i would not send my own you know i
actually you're too high profile
so another thing that happened was that
night was i don't really have like sexy
photos of myself
like i'm not like a you know you know me
i'm cute i'm adorable but i'm not like
out here you know with the tits out like
you know
pursing the lips um i you know i mean
with the with the with the booty perking
you know i don't have the booty so i i
use other ways anyway what am i saying
now i'm just spiraling
you're snake charming us not using your
body using your mouth i get it right
exactly now my
um i've already said too much this is
public
this is public i'm sweating right bumble
boy
um which could be a superhero
if he could suck his own dick he's
pretty much a superhero combo boy no
so i he was like send me a picture
and i don't have any sexy pictures and i
didn't want to take one in the moment
because obviously i wasn't looking
too on fleek so i sent like a really
cute selfie literally like the most
wholesome selfie ever
and i was into it and i didn't know what
he was gonna do with that he sends me a
video of my selfie
on an ipad like blown up big big picture
style
and then him um [ __ ] on top of it wow
good chicks love that by the way very
very we love it when technology's
involved
we love it when there's creativity a
steve yeah
a hand job if you will on the apple
product
he does on the apple why don't you just
print it out like we all do i mean i
think i didn't know if he had coloring
you know i was worrying about do you
have a screen protector i don't know
these are questions and you know what's
really funny
because i the selfie was taken at
anaheim convention center
i was there for like this event and then
it said at home convention center on the
photo you know
you have like a lanyard with a badge no
no badge no badge but i was very
wholesome selfie so that happened
anyway the point is we started off
raunchy so then
ever since then he just like will send
me like random videos of him doing
things hold on one second what do you
say to that
yeah oh yeah i was i think i was into it
i probably would like
to get that
like i'm a cupcake a little bit i'm a
cupcake yeah i'm a little croissant
yeah i'm a little ham and cheese
croissant blazing but you have to you
have to
you have to like reciprocate so what did
you do to reciprocate did you
no i did an ipad picture of him no ipad
picture i did at your sketch
i i i just guess it took me all night
like 45 minutes 3 a.m
i just sketched his penis and then i was
like
but then but then he um i even had to do
the little
the the the jizz you know the quick the
jizz the
little drops
um so then a couple of days later or
weeks later i don't know he ended up
sending me a video
of what i thought was him 69 with
another man
because the angle was like yeah i was
confused for a second it looked like
someone else's legs and a dick it was
basically his face the camera's here
his face and then a body
a penis upside down and a butt hole
whatever as if there's a tripod right
here neck
on like was he sleeping on his back yes
oh so he
did one of those bend the legs forward
he got his he got a stomach in his face
the opposite of a lazy boy you know what
i mean so
he um he sends me this video
of him sucking a penis and i was like oh
like i was like oh nice like i was just
thinking my head was like oh he's 69
with another guy and then my roommate
and i were looking at it we were kind of
analyzing you're seeing it together yeah
well
because it was like a painting it was
like a painting at a museum i was like
hey check this out what are you what are
you
doing what do you reckon what do you
reckon it's open was your picture on an
ipad also in that scene still though
not in the scene it wasn't like a
digital video it didn't make the scene
um unfortunately it got cut okay um
no he had to pay for the rights and it
was the whole thing like my lawyers
didn't want to get involved
um so i
he's sponsored by android products it is
a whole thing that i've had
um so so so then my roommate was like
that's him and i was like wait what and
we watched it i was like oh [ __ ] that is
him
so then i asked him i was like how many
people are in this video
that's what i said and then he said just
me sucking myself
and then i was like [ __ ] um i don't know
what i said i could actually look up
what i said
um i'm gonna show you guys a video after
we cut no
i'm chill i've seen it
sign up if you want to see steve suck
his own dick
patreon is the way to go baby do it that
time we're getting crazy
adrian only for the highest tiers
defibrillators level solution huh
you